here we go true or false another
confirmed
that's not now wait a minute i got i got
to throw the challenge flag and
overwrote this another confirmed
cheating incident tarnishes the patriots
dynasty who wrote that it's not a
confirmed church it's your show figure
out i don't know i didn't write it i
didn't write it it's not no okay well
it's no it's not the point because it's
a it's it's like when did you stop
beating your wife that's the type of
question it is it's a loaded question
another confirmed cheating incident
tarnishes the patriots dynasty false
false because it's not a cheating
incident chris no i agreed uh right i
mean this is what we argued about
yesterday yes false a hundred percent
you know
somebody's trying to somebody's trying
to stoke us into another fight well i'm
sick i'm sick of hearing people like and
again i know you and i stand on
different uh areas with deflategate
right and i know that's tom brady's
problem and to say all that too
listen he played in the super bowl 49 it
was awesome with the balls properly
inflated so it doesn't really matter but
i do i think you still did it yes now
the other stuff i'm so sick of hearing
people telling me about like oh the
patriots are so lucky the patriots cheat
no the patriots just work harder and
prepare harder than everybody else what
do they always say luck favors the
prepared right well that's why it favors
them more times than not i mean you know
anything you watch go on hbo and watch
saban and belichick and that show they
got on there that little documentary
right now i mean belichick is on another
level from the rest of football it's
constant like deep thinking about the
game that's why they win this has
nothing to do with cheating
and the reason that cheating comes into
play and i've had this explained to me
by multiple people over the years
because other teams can't compete with
the patriots when coaches and general
managers are called on the carpet by
their owners as to why we can't beat the
patriots and why aren't we like the
patriots they can't say because we're
just not good enough we don't work hard
enough we don't have the skills we don't
have the brain power you say they cheat
that's why they're better than a hundred
percent you know and i think i've said
this to you before it's been a while but
the amount of times i've had coaches
we're talking football and then my time
in new england comes up and i start to
discuss like how they do things there
they don't really ever want to hear
anymore or the follow-up there's no
follow-up questions like because they
they realize oh wow that's way detailed
overwhelming how does that guy even have
a life outside of football all of those
things and then it just ends to your
point so you're you're exactly right
and it applies in any industry and and
i've been there and i've done that and
from time to time i still deal with it
now anybody who works harder than anyone
else makes the people who aren't working
as hard look bad and they resent the
people who are working hard and they
come up with other reasons why hard work
is leading to good results because they
just don't want to put in the work yeah
plain and simple i agree they don't want
to put in the work agreed all right the
buffalo bills will win the afc is true
or false well i'm going to say false you
know again i think they're really
dangerous uh but gosh they got to play
sunday night football against the
pittsburgh steelers that's a tough
football game i would not be shocked if
they won i mean i might pick them to win
actually uh but i i gotta so true or
false well i'm saying false because i
got to see it to believe it for them to
beat the patriots head to head you know
that's just that's another animal
altogether i mean that's been like their
their big brother for the last 20 years
they can't ever seem to beat them the
patriots have their way and figure out
ways to win that way and you know in
those close tight football games too i
think the buffalo bills team is still
maturing and figuring out how to win
those type of games and they're not
always as perfect as maybe the new
england patriots are or have been
hey and that bill's patriots game coming
up in just 10 days that saturday of week
16. our guy mike taurico will be calling
it along with your guy kurt warner oh no
beckham jr and tom brady will be
teammates next season true or false oh
oh
i'm gonna say false i'm going to say
false but that's a very good question i
think there's like
i'm saying false for two reasons i mean
there's a lot of other teams that i
think would be interested in odell
beckham jr so that takes the chance away
of it being tom brady and odell beckham
jr the other thing i'll say is
i you also got to take into account if
tom brady will be in new england next
year i wouldn't be shocked if it's jared
stidham and odell beckham jr to go along
with it i know we've talked about this
this week a few times this has come out
the new england patriots are very high
on jared sidham i think they think he is
the future as of right now and you know
even if there's tom brady there or not
you know it does make sense to bring it
uh odell beckham jr in whether it's to
make your new starter thrive in a jared
siddom or give brady one more you know
chance a song song to go out in the
right way but i'm gonna say false just
because i think there'll be other teams
interested and i think there's a good
chance he's just back with the browns
i'm gonna say false just because there's
too many pieces too many parts too many
things that have to fall just right
right and and i know that odell beckham
jr would love to play with tom brady but
i think he's going to take whatever he
can get if he can get out of cleveland
and he still wants to go to san
francisco that video is floating around
of him talking to jimmy garoppolo about
you know basically
what seems to be and there's different
interpretations of what they're saying
but the the general consensus is they're
having a conversation about otto beckham
jr trying to get to san francisco and
play with jimmy garoppolo and the 49ers
so i think beckham's main objective is
going to be get out of cleveland he's
not going to be as picky about landing
with tom brady we don't know where tom
brady's gonna land you really i mean all
right two questions all right i don't
think o'dell really wants to leave
cleveland i don't think he's like i want
out of here i don't i don't believe it i
don't know i don't have inside
information too the other thing is do
you think john dorsey would really trade
him away knowing that there's still such
great potential there if he gets the
right head coach or right group around
him to to kind of bring it all out
well i believe completely jay glazer's
report that odell beckham jr was telling
players and coaches from opposing teams
come get me yeah so if he's doing that
he wants out of cleveland yeah the
question becomes will the browns try to
salvage the relationship maybe through
the hiring of a new coach maybe john
dorsey brings buddy boy into the office
you know the whole buddy boy with the
chewing gum and buddy
and tries to convey hey buddy boy you
know we're going to have this new coach
and he's got a plan for using your buddy
boy and and and maybe he can get odell
beckham jr to buy in and having jarvis
landry in the locker room is a major
draw to keep oto beckham jr 100
right but but i think otto beckham jr
sees on the inside what we see on the
outside the freddie kitchen's just
hitting the guy i'm sorry we've seen the
evidence over and over again the lack of
discipline for the team the inability to
come up with ways to use otto beckham jr
that don't feel forced and artificial
and and if you get a new coach that may
change things all right lamar jackson is
more dangerous than patrick mahomes true
or false whoa holy crap we're just
coming in with the hard stuff here oh
i'm gonna go i'm gonna say false i'm
gonna say false i mean that i don't feel
confident about saying it but yeah i
mean i still think patrick mahomes is
you know arguably the most dangerous
quarterback in football i do yeah i do
just with not only the weapons around
him but some of the damnedest plays on a
week-to-week basis where the play has
broken down and he still makes something
crazy happen uh it's very close i know
lamar jackson's on fire but i guess what
i'm thinking too is i guess i got to see
a little bit of lamar and play off
football too to maybe make me feel a
little bit better like i know patrick
mahomes can be dangerous and play off
football too we witnessed it in person
we saw him be very dangerous in the afc
championship game so i'm going to give
him the slight edge
yeah
lamar jackson i'm going lamar jackson
because right now jackson is the guy
that no one has begun to figure out and
that running threat makes it easier to
pass and what he does as a passer
creates those openings to run you know
that that run against the the rams a
couple of weeks ago that just kind of
stole their souls late in the first half
right that came on a passing play where
he's just like oh you know what
nothing's there i'm gone and then you
have to constantly account for both of
the things that he can do very well so
i'm going to say lamar jackson for now
the cowboys will miss the playoffs if
they lose to the rams this week true or
false false i mean hey you know they're
competing with the eagles the eagles can
lose to anybody this week it doesn't
matter i mean the eagles i can't sit
here and just say oh they're gonna go to
who the eagles got the washington
redskins this week i mean i expect them
to win but nonetheless even if the
cowboys lose this week it still comes
down to the week 16 matchup the
head-to-head matchup against them and
the eagles so i'm saying false
yeah i agree with you it all comes down
to week 16 whoever wins that game in
philadelphia is going to win the
division
make the playoffs and have the home game
that goes along with it hosting the five
seed which most likely would be the
49ers or the seahawks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports